son más de 45 periodistas y fotógrafos
los que han sido detenidos desde que
comenzaron las protestas en Irán sin
embargo la mayor preocupación está en
dos mujeres periodistas ni lugarni y el
ajemo jamadí periodistas de dos
importantes periódicos en Irán que en su
momento hablaron y informaron sobre la
muerte de maxamney en el caso de nirofar
que estuvo en el hospital y de la fe que
estuvo en la ciudad de saques donde era
originaria esta joven y asistió a el
entierro en su momento el jefe de este
periódico dijo que ella había estado ahí
porque ella porque él lo había enviado
como lo haría cualquier periodista
normal sin embargo hoy habló el portavoz
del sistema judicial y dijo que las
acusan de atentar contra la seguridad
del estado y también de difundir
propaganda en contra de la República
islámica ya días atrás un comunicado
conjunto entre el de inteligencia Y el
departamento de inteligencia de la
guardia Revolucionaria dos instituciones
que generalmente no trabajan juntas las
acusaron a las dos de haber sido
entrenadas por la inteligencia
norteamericana por la Cia y habían dicho
que tanto ninfar en su momento había
publicado la foto de maxa en el hospital
cuando estaba convaleciente algo que su
esposo ha negado y también decía que
lagía había publicado fotos que habían
incitado y han dado el dolor de la
familia así que la preocupación crece
por lo que pueda pasar por estas dos
periodistas que sus compañeros sus
colegas y sus jefes de los medios han
salido a defender